well i'll tell you what what freaks me
out with this this ukraine uh story with
russia uh ian just mentioned the
sudetenland
hitler kept going saying look these
areas were historically german or the
people there are being oppressed and
they're german people so we're going to
move in and what we got from uh from the
uk or from europe neville chamberlain
famously was appeasement right over and
over and over again as this this
psychopath was not only killing tons of
people or had you know it was planning
to uh was
co invading other countries and then
trying to just basically take over i
would i would argue as take over the
world or you know claim as much land as
possible
we look what vladimir putin's done with
with crimea
and now we're looking at what he's doing
with uh the donbass region
if he really does go for a third of the
country he's got to move in further it's
not just going to be the downbass region
and it's a small portion right no right
so you'd go south and you'd go he could
keep cut down so yeah yeah you want to
connect those borders so you want to you
want to meet up with belarus there
because now you've already annexed it to
one degree and then you want to go down
and make a connection to crimea i mean
that looks like more like half the
country if he goes from belarus all the
way down to crimea no i'm not i'm just
saying where you have that land bridge
so you just you want to have the ability
then to remove supplies it's about
supply lines right right and and so
you've uh are are we is is joe biden our
neville chamberlain is he's gonna is he
gonna sit back and be like oh you know
look we're going to what what did he say
in that speech he was like
you know it depends on if it's a minor
incursion right yeah that seemed like a
gaffe i don't i don't think that was
what he was in
wasn't was on the list for him to say
it's i think he it's possible it could
have been a signal that you know
this much would be acceptable right i
think it was a gaffe
but i think he said the the quiet part
loud yeah i think joe biden and you know
the state department they said we can
tolerate a minor incursion we can't do
more than that and biden blurted out on
national tv and putin went really right
okay because it doesn't change things to
to much of a degree because those areas
were already occupied right they say
they don't have russian troops there but
they have russian mercenaries which are
just
guys straight out of the military going
there i mean special forces all in there
uh
you know you just don't wear the uniform
right just like they did in crimea
so
it it well it does change things because
from what we're talking about is this is
literally an invasion because you're
you're
breaking away international
laws precedences and going across
sovereign border but he already built
the case that that's not true
they asked for independence
we
recognize it and so
but what's the point of it's kind of
silly that putin is like well they're
independent states and they've asked for
help it's like who believes you the
people who already side with you his
people well the russians believe him but
is that really the issue though he's
trying to generate popular support
within russia no but you got to be able
to say your boldface lie with a straight
face yeah right so you have to have some
argument
that's true i guess if he didn't have
that he'd be telling the people of his
own country we're just trampling over
other countries yeah or but more more
importantly the u.n security council
that's where you got to be able but do
they really believe no but it doesn't
matter yeah because he can
he can and in a way it is justified but
so thinking back to the one thing he
really
can truly say is
that nato is really encroaching on his
border right and i mean he can say that
there's truth in that now if you put
yourself in russian shoes you don't want
nato as any closer to you than possibly
they can right
and and so
granted that but to go about it in this
way i mean obviously is
uh the only way he feels he can't
accomplish the buffer that he's looking
for and he's looking for a buffer
you think it's really that i mean with
uh with crimea it's because they have uh
they have the military base there is
that isn't that what the reason was well
yeah well they're just naval base right
so now they have all of what they didn't
have as far as naval infrastructure
and so
and of course listen all you have to do
is pull up
a map of the pipelines leaving russia
and it makes complete sense of
everything that's going on as well i
mean at the end of the day that's what
it's all about ukraine the pipeline's
running through ukraine yeah one of the
biggest so and you have another one
going through
um belarus and like i told you
alexander lukashenko was such a big
thorn now that thorn's gone
and at the end of the day this is the
only way he truly can stay equal with
nato it's through the resources that
they're all dependent on so he has a
plan for the nordstrom deal or else he
he wouldn't be doing this either so
crimea is basically a way to get oil out
of
russia yeah well it gives you the porch
but it also gave you now a southern
route of attack
yeah and uh it's it's a phenomenal
position for a world war that the crimea
and the baltic is that the baltic sea
black sea oh my gosh what an amazing
that's that's their only warm water port
right right yeah so they they when when
with nato moving in on ukraine and this
is one of the big issues pertaining to
uh the euromaidan movement yanukovych
being ousted
ukraine trying to join nato or align
with the european union whatever it was
russia's thinking we'll lose crimea and
we need that access so they said we're
going to take it now or forever hold our
peace so then a referendum was held in
crimea and they all voted to join russia
oh yeah there you go is that simple i
mean
and that's the thing so if
if zielinski wasn't there we wouldn't be
going through this because he is clearly
pro-west
he is looking to get into nato nato's
not really that interested because they
understand the consequences and
being realistic they understand he does
need a buffer i mean
both sides understand that
but
if if like the former president there in
ukraine if he would have been russian
leaning we'd just we wouldn't be looking
at it wasn't yanukovych russian leading
yes and then he fled to russia after he
got out so what people got to understand
is um when we have these conversations
it's always from an american perspective
yeah the russian perspective is more
that the u.s is orchestrating an ousting
of yanukovych to put in pro-western
leaders they do the same thing with
syria i'd say it's probably half true
you got it you got to come absolutely
why wouldn't we well you got to cut
through the propaganda and then figure
out what's really going on and
the the the view of a lot of these
people is that the protests in ukraine
were supported by the west to try and
get rid of a guy who was more favorable
towards russia or at the very least was
kind of playing that game where he was
like what are you going to give me what
are you going to give me you know oh
absolutely we do it all over the world
we've been doing it forever
i mean every side does this it is kind
of funny though
that now russia is playing this game and
america you know joe biden's like how
dare you and putin's probably going like
bro he's like you've been playing this
game well longer than i have yeah you
know now i do it you get mad about it
well yeah we do
i guess so it's it it's tough you know
what what moral uh uh pedestal does the
united states have to stand on when
russia is playing the same game other
than we are powerful and we can tell you
not to do it
no
it's a it's very difficult and again
honestly i'm no fan of this current
administration right i mean as an
organization we're apolitical because we
deal with threats we don't deal with
who's causing the threat right there has
to be a realization of that but if
you're looking to analyze this thing
you can't take the past actions
and allow it
to warp you to not see something for
what it is so i agree the whole thing
about the border but it really doesn't
have anything to do with the truth of
why we shouldn't not uh
not be in nato and why there isn't a
reason for us to at least be making sure
that this doesn't spread i think you
made a great point though the southern
border
board the southern border policy
is to be is to be weak that is it yeah
so by design so when people are coming
out and they're being like why why
aren't we defending our own borders like
well they it's that's the opposite of
what they want right they absolutely
don't want it right
that's a proven fact now yeah
well that just says to me that i think
you know ian's talking about this this
global what do you call it like liberal
economic order liberal economic order i
guess some people call it the davos
group or the great reset or that kind of
a form of 1946 is when they formed the
liberal economic order right after world
war ii when you have when you have an
administration
that uh tells canada you know by
administration hey use emergency powers
crack down to an extreme degree and they
do when you have an administration that
says our policy is for the southern u.s
border to be just completely open and
then we're going to go defend and worry
about russia and ukraine yeah it just
sends a hard signal i understand why we
care you know we don't want this you
know things firing out of control but it
certainly just seems like biden's
priority is not america no right so it's
frustrating right but i guess you know
i guess i would just say don't become so
jaded that you don't you simply because
you don't like what's going on in the
border you don't realize the importance
of ukraine that's all i'm saying keep it
keep keep one separate from the other
because they are two separate things and
while one may really frustrate you
and
don't underestimate the importance of
what's going on there i i wonder though
just you know one last thought on all of
this you know
what's the probability you think this
could spiral into a greater conflict
beyond just the small this region
the possibility definitely exists i
don't think that would be the plan in
the immediate um
but i don't think it's ever the plan
right well i the plan is you know it has
been
take crimea subjugate belarus get
portions of ukraine he's clearly had
this plan been working on it for a
little while it's all coming to fruition
because there is
no uh
there is really nothing we can do but to
try to keep it from spiraling right
if he wants it he can take it that no
one would no one's saying otherwise the
ukrainian forces cannot stop the initial
assault now they can become partisans
and turn this into a guerrilla type
warfare true
and that's more probably what he doesn't
want than anything he wants to topple
this government though he wants
zielinski out and he'll do that by any
means and the fact is where does the
calculate has he calculated right or
hasn't he i'll say you know that i i see
i see two potentials when we look back
at what germany did with you know as
against to reference what he inside the
sudan lands and uh the appeasement
that that was only the war that broke
out was one potential of what what could
have happened and we look back on
history and we say
look at what germany did it led to war
therefore these things lead to war it's
not necessarily true
that time it did in this instance we
could sit back and just appease and try
and placate come out and say peace in
our time whatever nonsense and and maybe
vladimir putin will take the don best
region and just stop
there's no guarantee that actually turns
into world war iii but i will add it is
it is a a variable that could lead to
that point it is it is a moment in time
that could lead to a very similar
circumstance it's hard to know if it
will though and what do you do do we as
americans say
we can't allow russia to they they've
they've used this strategy over and over
again i guess they used it in what was
georgia they played this game yeah they
do with crimea if we sit back and it's
five ten years later and now a third of
ukraine is under is under russian
control as a satellite state
do we just let that keep happening until
the baltic states you know are now just
under the boot of russia
do we intervene what happens if we don't
what happens if lithuania belarus or i
need these other countries poland loses
their mind saying like we are not going
to allow that because they certainly
don't like what the soviet union was all
about
what happens if that just breaks out
into a war in europe we stay out of it
saying we don't want to be involved
china moves on taiwan
now there's fighting in the pacific
there's fighting in eastern europe the
u.s begins doing weapons deals with uh
european countries and then china says
you are funding our enemies and then
bombs pearl harbor
oh
yeah we could talk for a long time on
how far could yesterday be the
absolutely and
the you know what they would say
they would they we talk we talk about
how uh between world war one and world
war ii it was one war with a 20-year
armistice or something like that that
was just reignited from the same
grievances
you could argue that this is a remnant
of the same of the end of world war ii
the difference would be china wouldn't
bomb pearl harbor although they might
they would bomb san francisco new york
washington d.c
uh dallas
they would buy um kansas city they'd
bomb seattle they all at once it would
all happen in a day in in an hour
i used bombing of pearl harbor not in a
literal sense but to make a point to be
clear too the similarities between world
war ii and what we're seeing here uh i'm
not so sure china how many nukes do they
have like 50 they don't have money do
they no they they've they got plenty
plenty enough you only need one right
well right nuclear submarines off the
west coast there's the most dangerous
part right russia has got more than they
could possibly use
same thing with us you know i was in
nukes for five years we had 12 rush i
was stationed in germany we had 12
nuclear uh missiles pointed at russia 24
7. wow
12 that you knew of
yeah that so what we did was we rotated
we rotated one battalion does it for 30
days because it's around the clock if
you're in the shower and the alarm goes
off you have 30 seconds to make it to
the gate and get those missiles launched
because our life expectancy was 30
seconds what what
what year was this so that would have
been 89 these were pershing two missiles
so they were short range could hit they
come within 10 meters of their target
and you're talking about a nuke you you
don't have to come that close right but
but it was low yeah they'll blow up in
the air no these were made to hit
targets interesting yeah and so
now we on salt 2 treaty we did away with
them and that was for to everybody to
back down right because we're getting
towards the end of the cold war
let's not have so many of these just
sitting there active ready to go
and and so those were done away with
that's when i so my basically my mos was
no longer and that's when i switched it
to the military
was it was it under trump the start
treaty basically fell apart
yeah denuclearization started to
well it's because everybody else never
follows it right i mean russia breaks it
all the time iran's broken it all the
time that's what gets so frustrating
although you have to sit down at the
table you have to do it
but it it never really solves i think
weapons
look with the manhattan project you had
this decentralization the
compartmentalization people didn't know
what was being what was being done until
after a bunch of bombs fell and all of a
sudden everyone figured out what america
had done and uh the decades after that
the the nuclear weapons um we have today
are about 1 000 to 1 251 000 to 1250
times more powerful than the bombs we
used in world war ii and that's
something yeah one icbm
a mirv a multiple independently targeted
reentry vehicle carrying 10 to 12
warheads peppers the eastern seaboard
you don't need 50 nukes no you don't you
need 10 warheads in one icbm and then it
goes up into the stratosphere and this
goes
and they all just go up
wipe out cities and i mean these things
are massively powerful not to mention
the latest developments and this is i
think this is actually like seven years
ago i was researching this in gravity
bomb technology which is the bombs we
used in world war ii are gravity bombs
we drop them from planes
we don't launch them or anything we've
compressed those down really really
small megaton bombs so they're they're
very small
and and comparably is powerful
the weapons that we know about scary i
mean think about nuclear artillery oh
yeah
i haven't looked into it but how how
what are the actual artillery pieces
that can launch nukes no put what load
of warhead and howitzer you're right i
mean there's a there's different
versions of what can do what but
just
the idea that these types of
capabilities exist is
why we don't use them okay because in
the end
nobody wants to really blow up the
planet right so it's been a it has
worked in deterring
it it's not going to stop everything
but it has worked in deterring
i guess it's partly it makes me think
like why if china invades taiwan no one
is going to try and stop it if russia
takes crimea or belarus no one's going
to stop it if america takes mexico no
one's going to stop it because no one
wants well these conquering empires to
fire their nukes taiwan is very
sensitive because they make 63
of all the chips that we are already
short of
63
if i'm accurate
that's huge what is it the kind of thing
where like it's better that no one has
it than china has it
well if they dominate that market right
we so you see the pictures of i saw one
this week where ford broncos are piling
up in the parking lot again because
uh the shortage of chips
and that's because we don't produce them
here which we're trying to rectify right
there's a lot of things we're trying to
rectify because we've seen our our
weakness through kovid and how much
control china has over these things add
in taiwan to that
and it just that
it would [ __ ] technology yeah so yeah
it's very important we would do
something but is that the kind of thing
where we would like scorched earth the
place and be like hey you can't take
this from us you can have you can have
nothing and none of us get it well we
would i would imagine we would literally
actively try to stop them right and and
that's going to have to do with all
naval power because
you know we
that's where you you send the seven
fleets right if
that's where we're gonna have to start
because that china has slowly been
building those islands to claim that
entire region but also to give them a
place to launch something militarily
building islands is a smart move very
smart and so that means you know the
marines would have a tough job yeah
that's what they'd have to clear they
did surround taiwan and blockade the the
island i would imagine the chinese yeah
so you think there'd be like c c battles
right no there'd be a air foot right in
here on the sea because we don't have
troops on the ground yeah if china and
the united states ever
fight each other that's like the
beginning of total war i i think limited
war is when like the taiwanese forces
are fighting the the belarusian forces
and they're both funded by
one side or the other americans are
funding the taiwanese and the chinese
are funding yeah so fortunately the
right for us there's a great distance
between us and china us in russia other
than alaska
right because all you have there is the
baron c but uh
i mean that's what's kept the peace
right and and that's been our that's
been our beauty
we've had
canada and we've had mexico there's no
threat there right militarily we have a
sweet spot right here so it's not easy
for to get to us therefore we have to
project power that's why we make our
navy what it is and and that helps us to
control the situation until you can
actually then get the rest of what's
needed boots on the ground the supplies
that go into all that and again that's
why
not being a part of nato would would not
be smart i'm gonna i wanna make another
point too is you know especially as
we're talking about nuclear weapons
america is is is
the united states great geography in
terms of war just because we we've got
both coasts we've got the interstate
highway system which is the mountainside
seriously and then i was thinking about
you know but what if you know we're
talking about nuclear weapons you know
ian you're mentioning china we just wipe
out all these cities i tell you this
even if
the u.s got nuked to kingdom come by you
know dozens of warheads they would still
not be able no one would be able to
conquer this this country for one reason
the sheer amount of guns that exist here
even after we've been nuked yank coming
in although and i'm thinking about that
video game fallout which i love fallout
3 and i'm imagining like
in this game in the fallout series
you're finding guns and bullets
everywhere and i'm like actually it
makes sense but what if the game took
place in china or in australia that
you'd find none
so thinking about that if nuclear war
really broke out you know there's a
quote from einstein i know not what
world war three what uh i know not what
weapons world war three will be fought
with but world war four will be thought
fought with sticks and stones and i'm
like
i i don't know i think world war iv
would just be the united states armed to
the teeth with all of the insane amount
of guns they have and then they would
just conquer everybody i don't know it's
not the disease that i'm concerned like
the native americans 95 percent of them
were wiped out by smallpox when the
settlers came over numbers i've heard i
could see like nuclear war and then just
disease cause kills the all these people
with their guns that just starve and run
out of water and then get sick and die
and then someone comes in to clean it up
so we're strong enough now right
but we used to live in the united states
of america we now live in the divided
states of america
and herein will be our achilles heel
because
politically
and culturally there does not seem to be
a path
back to
normalcy
where we could get five individuals
six into this room and speak like
rational adults
right the conversation is no longer
happening
and
i don't i don't know how we turn that
corner
because it it it's just we just seen it
with canada we would never would have
guessed right that it would have gone to
that extreme
and and report the problem is
now this is happening at the level of
our children because of the foolishness
in schools
and listen i i
you know i sort of understand the
argument but let me make one thing
personally clear
no one on the face of the planet is
going to make me feel guilty for being
born
right
so i did not choose where when and to
whom i had nothing nothing to say in
that matter but people on the other side
of this politically and culturally
you're not going to understand that
language that you're speaking you know
the languages are so different so you
juxtapose at this point like you really
can't communicate that's why that's
normal divide and i get that believe me
so
i'm not going to go out and try to do no
harm to anybody else but
they will no one will make me feel
guilty for being me but what happens
when they show up to your neighborhood
with guns
what happens when they're marching
through your streets arm telling you you
can't drive your car through here
anymore and they point rifles at you so
this is the problem this is what we're
seeing up in portland and it just
culminated in a very serious incident
over the weekend where uh a guy is
critically injured four uh four others i
think uh three other uh so there's a
total of five people were shot one died
the the guy in conflict with antifa was
critically injured and three other
antifa were were seriously injured put
in the hospital i believe they were
arrested in the er
you know we had um i know i've been
mentioning it quite a bit in the past
few episodes but i think it's important
we had stephen marsh he wrote this book
it's a wave it up there in the wall uh
the next civil war
he said this country is a multicultural
democracy and a constitutional republic
inside at the same time and they can't
coexist
he he said you know you mentioned just
now how do we turn that corner he said
when will you something effective when
will you realize you in this country
like what's happening
my view is you know what i told him was
as a canadian you love your socialized
healthcare okay you give that up you
abolish that we go private we have peace
and he said point taken
based on what you're saying about people
making you feel guilty for for being
born
when if someone comes up to me these
these these uh democrats out of
california they wanted to repeal the
civil rights language from their
constitution the language that says you
cannot discriminate on the basis of race
gender identity etc they said we want
that gone we want that right
i say no
no compromise
so how do we don't so anyway to kind of
bring this back to where we were with
war and nuclear weapons and stuff i
think our achilles heel is exactly the
right point
when uh jesse kelly today
he's a funny guy he tweeted that um i
mean seriously but he made a good point
he said we need a national divorce
because um democrat voters are polled
showing they support what trudeau was
doing with this authoritarianism
and the scary thing is i don't think
he's wrong but i think if he's right and
we do have a national divorce
russia walks all over eastern europe
takes what it wants china takes taiwan
they both expand exponentially
and that's it we now as americans live
under heavy trade restrictions and under
the boot of these
mostly china
it wouldn't be the united states
necessarily because who knows what would
happen to this country but it's not just
going to be fighting here it's going to
be us
being subjugated by oppressive forces
from china from the communist party from
their allies from russia
when it comes to trade especially no
without a doubt and that again that's
why our strength right we've lost our
strength by
not being the united states of america
and uh
i mean that's why fortitude ranch exists
this is why we're trying to have 12
ranches across the country so that
hopefully you wouldn't have to drive any
more than one gas tank
but you've played fallout oh yeah video
game how amazing would it be that if in
the real world they weren't vaults they
were fortitude ranchers
and there's there's six you know there's
500 of them or whatever you guys become
this major conglomerate corporation
everybody lines up you do these
spiffy 50s style tv ads come sign up for
fortitude you know you gotta go
somewhere when the bombs drop right yeah
come on down
as funny as that is that'd be great on
the game you're working on right working
fortitude tokens instead of uh caps
bottle caps yeah instead of bottle caps
right but you guys should have a bunch
of bottle caps that'd be funny yeah this
is invisible as a bit i know when you
when people show up to sign up for the
ranch be like here's what we used to
trade
see how many of them get the reference i
know i wonder if they would i mean
considering they're familiar with you
know survival camps or fortitude they
might understand the joke yeah and you
know our membership um
has has changed over the years it used
to be more of the along the hardcore
prepper type
uh but once covid hit uh things started
to change but once civil and rest hit
that changed everything people uh
man
they take everything for granted
absolutely
the normalcy bias is what really really
gets me the optimism bias and the
normalcy bias optimism meaning that
people think bad things won't happen and
normalcy they think things can't change
but boy can they change and they can
change fast i mean that's why i point
out this the first civil war in the
united states nobody thought it was
going to happen
because everybody just thinks world war
one too that just happened so fast all
of a sudden one day it was the world was
a piece the next day
we got a guy got assassinated and we try
to be rational about it right last time
i was on it was about a year ago you
asked me what you thought the percentage
was of you know seeing some real
violence as we turned the corner of the
election i said five percent and you're
kind of surprised um that i would say
five percent but as you saw see the
things weren't in place was it because i
thought it would be higher or lower
higher i thought it'd be higher yeah and
the
especially right because i'm the
fortitude ranch guy so it would seem
like you've got an economic incentive to
tell everybody 100 exactly exactly
right so we don't play the fear game i
mean that's not what that what it's
about right
and and again so we as an organization
we stay political so that we could
really try to have the right data we
never activated for covid we did
activate and that's how you actually
invited me to the show for the election
and yeah that was a given opportunity
for all the new members basically to
come bring their supplies and get to
know him right it was basically uh let's
sit and watch the elections kind of get
together we really weren't
thinking that it was going to be and
that's another reason why you thought it
would probably be higher because we
activated it for the first time in
existence but i also had i think you
guys got to activate this november
oh well so now here's the thing right we
haven't even gotten into that
so there's no path it seems like going
forward and now things are going to get
loonier
you thought trump point one was
something wait for trump point two
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time